désaccord profond avec cette résiliation
beaucoup de questions qui ont été posées
en conseil d'administration qui n'ont
absolument pas reçu de réponse est une
vraie incertitude sur la suite et la
continuité du transport sur le centre de
la martinique
ça fait un an je vous pour vos 365 jours
que la décision de résiliation été prise
le 17 décembre 2018 qu'est ce qui s'est
passé entre temps et aujourd'hui on
vient nous dire dans six mois on aura un
nouveau service qui va être mis en place
avec un établissement industriel
commercial avec des marchés qui vont
être passées aujourd'hui dans le même
conseil d'administration on a été obligé
de modifier des conventions pour les
marchés du nord avec l'obligation faite
par l'état de passer des délégations de
service public
dix-huit mois délai pour passer ces dsp
et en conseil d'administration on nous
explique que 18 mois ce ne sera pas
suffisant donc de côté pour organiser le
transport de la drogue 18 mois ce sera
pas suffisant mais aujourd'hui là on
vient me dire à moi mais à beaufonds de
france que dans six mois on aura
organisé le transport et qu'on va passer
des marchés je suis désolé mais je n'y
crois pas j'ai donc beaucoup de
questions pas de réponse est en réalité
tout ce que moi je vois derrière tout ça
c'est juste une manoeuvre politicienne
ça fait un an que martinique transports
a pris cette décision j'ai voté contre
la dernière fois j'ai encore voter
contre aujourd'hui est d'autant plus
convaincu que je n'ai aucune réponse à
ces questions là donc je ne fais pas
l'interprétation je dis ça fait un an 17
décembre que la décision était prise de
dénoncer le contrat si aujourd'hui à
trois mois des élections que on vient
finalement passer et dire que ça sera le
31 juillet on a vu ce qui s'est passé
après la décision du 17 décembre 2018 on
a vu les paquets a eu sous les
commerçants de fort de france
je ne suis pas paranoïaque mais quand
même je me pose des questions sur les
motivations et les réelles motivations
qu'il y a et personne n'a été capable de
me dire en conseil d'administration
qu'est ce qui va se passer le 1er août